oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine jean louis debré bonjour jean
louis debré alors je vous êtes dans un
studio à paris nous sommes dans deux
studios séparés pour respecter
évidemment le protocole sanitaire
vous êtes dans le centre de paris et
puis moi ici dans les studios de
boulogne jean louis debré je vais pas
repasser comme ça le film de votre
carrière à vous êtes un politique
c'était un peu dans l'adn familiale même
si votre formation de base c'était la
magistrature
vous avez été député ministre de
l'intérieur surtout avec jacques chirac
dont vous étiez très proche
et puis président du conseil
constitutionnel gardiens de la
constitution dont votre père faut-il le
rappeler
michel debré était l'auteur ou l'un des
auteurs vous êtes maintenant écrivains
en quelque sorte puisque romancier vous
publiez la rumeur chez robert laffont
c'est pas votre premier coup d'essai ça
dans la littérature vous êtes assez
prolifique en matière de deux livres
saints polar une fois de plus qui se
situe dans les milieux du pouvoir alors
quels sont les comptes que vous aviez à
régler pour mettre en place un tel
scénario dont on dira un peu quelques
clics et quelques bribes dans un instant
je n'ai aucun aucun compte à régler
j'ai observé j'ai regardé est ce qui est
assez fascinant aujourd'hui différence
de ce qui se passait jadis c'est que la
rumeur
le bruit a plus d'importance dans le
monde de la politique que la vérité et
la réalité
les politiques quels qu'ils soient
réagissent en fonction de rumeurs de
bruits de malveillance qui sont répandus
dans notre société notre société est
ainsi faite que par la présence des
réseaux sociaux de l'hyper médiatisation
on ne sait plus très bien ce qui est
fondé de ce qui ne l'est pas et dans ce
monde politique que j'ai observé qu
observer comme
l'intérieur comme parlementaire comme
président de l'assemblée comme président
du conseil constitutionnel
je me rendais compte que bien souvent
les réactions elle était elle n'avait
aucun rapport avec les réalités et
c'était la différence entre mon métier
de magistrat ou pour mettre en cause
quelqu'un il faut des preuves et la
politique où on met quelqu'un en cause
uniquement sur des bruits des rumeurs
des on dit et donc ce qui m'amusait
c'est ces deux parce que j'ai pas
suffisamment de talent pour tout inventé
ce qui m'amuse et c'est d'introduire
cette rumeur dans le monde politique et
dans les rapports entre entre les hommes
politiques alors ccc c'est ça le message
que vous vouliez faire passer avec un
scénario vous dites que vous n'avez pas
forcément le talent qui est quand même
assez bien fille c'est parce que d'un
côté il ya un président de la république
dont on dit qu'il serait malade c'est la
rumeur aussi hein et puis de l'autre on
découvre à peu près au même moment qu'il
ya un agent russe comme par hasard qui a
été assassiné et on raconte plus ou
moins au bout d'un moment on comprend
que cet agent russe était à paris sans
doute pour fomenter un complot et pour
empêcher peut-être le président d'être
réélu c'est un peu ça à l'histoire mais
rien n'est sûr rien n'est sûr quand vous
êtes en responsabilité quels que soient
vos responsabilités qu'à une rumeur qui
court sur vous immédiatement au savoir
qui est à l'origine de la rumeur
d'où elle vient qui l'a fait partir et
pourquoi et vous avez à ce moment là
dans les cercles du pouvoir des gens qui
vous disent à mai mais cette rumeur je
sais je sais elle vient de l'extérieur
elle vient de l'étranger ils veulent
influencer sur les élections
je sais j'ai des preuves et puis vous
avez mis le petit qu'ils ont ce sont vos
adversaires mais je sais bien qu'ils y
répondent cette idée
et comme par hasard pardonner noir comme
par hasard la rumeur là il vient et elle
vise les russes quoi hein si vous voulez
il ya tout un contexte qui qui a trait
sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas vrai mais
aux états unis on voit et puis dire ici
ou là on voit des espions russes
mystérieusement assassiné pour pour moi
la russie considère toujours l'occident
comme un adversaire
et puis la construction d'une europe
forte ne gêne un peu la russie bref même
si les conséquences de yalta ont disparu
on est toujours dans un affrontement
et puis il faut trouver une victime foot
vous donner un bon résultat bhl et ceux
coupables
c'est forcément une puissance étrangère
parce que c'est les réflexes toujours
d'aller voir ailleurs
plutôt que de voir chez soi ces appuis
champ extérieur
mais on sait on sait où on en est
certain et finalement c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça mais alors comment
expliquez vous justement que le
complotisme a autant de succès et se
développe non seulement dans le domaine
politique
mais dans le domaine sanitaire dans le
domaine de l'actualité qui nous
préoccupe et qui est très anxiogène
actuellement parce que parce que pour
plusieurs raisons parce que précisément
parce qu'il est anxiogène
ça donne la place ça libère toutes les
énergies les plus diverses
deuxièmement j'ai été très frappée
pendant pendant notre premier
confinement où j'ai un peu regardé la
télévision
il faut vraiment être très équilibré
pour ne pas
s'interroger sur ce qui se passe parce
que vous avez tous les médecins qui
défilent tous les grands spécialistes
qui défilent chacun dit le contraire de
l'autre puis vous allez politiques qui
sont tous en train de se critiquer et
sur ce terrain de l'incertitude de
langoat et bien se développe tout ce qu'
il y adeux de personnages qui aiment le
complot qui aime qui aiment semer le
doute
voilà donc aujourd'hui s'appelait jean
louis debré sans trahir de secrets
d'état
vous avez été au coeur du pouvoir
pendant de nombreuses années notamment
au ministère de l'intérieur dont on
connaît la proximité avec les disait est
ce que dans votre dans votre vie
professionnelle
vous avez participé à aa des à des
conventions ou à des eaux à des
séminaires faisant état d'une possible
pandémie de cette ampleur là n'ont pas
pas mon époque parce que c'était il ya
quand même 25 ans mais on avait on avait
l'angoissent parce que c'était ça va
être déjà été le cas dans un certain de
pays on avérés les terroristes avaient
répondu du gaz saran on s'était
interrogé comment lutter contre ce
développement de d'une intoxication
voulu alors on ne parlait pas de
pandémie à l'époque mais il y avait dans
la réflexion politique et sécuritaire
une réflexion pour dire mais que se
passera-t-il si au lieu de 2,2 de poser
une bombe
les terroristes ou un groupe
d'anarchistes que vous voulez répandent
des gaz et c'est ce qui s'est passé dans
un mètre d'un métro je crois à londres
en chine ou au japon
alors on remet même à londres aussi et
et à bruxelles
oui c'est ça c'est ça c'est une angoisse
c'était une angoisse déjà à cette époque
oui à
la pandémie vous venez de dire comment
vous avez vécu le premier confinement
moi j'aimerais vous demander comment
vous vous juger où vous lisez les
décisions qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement pour répondre à cette
pandémie
ce sont des missions qui font débat
d'abord parce que elles sont très
restrictives ils sont jugés par beaucoup
comme liberticide et puis d'autre part
elles sont très préjudiciable à
l'activité économique
donc elles peuvent aussi faire du mal au
niveau de l'activité du chômage de
l'emploi et des aides et de la
croissance
alors j'ai toujours admiré de ceux ou
celles qui disent il ya qu'à faut qu'on
will trop facile lâche c'est trop facile
de d'avoir une position sur un phénomène
qu'on n'a pas imaginé
donc on n'a pas évalué l'importance au
départ et qui arrive tout d'un coup
simplement chose que je trouve c'est que
dans ces cas là il faut avoir le courage
de la halle de la vérité et ne pas
chercher à cacher là la vérité ce que la
situation telle que l' on la retrouve
on la vit et que trop souvent les
pouvoirs publics en france comme
ailleurs n'ont pas voulu admettre la
vérité
ils ont voulu le cacher à après
qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux il vaut mieux
sauver des vies ou permettre à
l'économie de fonctionner ce sont des
choix
aucun aucun des deux choix n'est parfait
je crois que il faut trouver un
équilibre cet équilibre il est difficile
à trouver mais
il est évident que dans les périodes oui
est-ce que l'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel que vous êtes à un avis
sur l'utilisation du droit sur
l'utilisation de l'état d'urgence dans
dans la lutte contre contre un phénomène
comme celui ci alors l'état d'urgence
sanitaire auquel fait allusion a été
voté par le parlement
oui donc par les représentants du peuple
c'est la loi et elle doit se respecter
et le conseil constitutionnel a rendu
une décision disant qu'il avait il a
modifié quelques petites choses mais
c'était compatible avec le respect des
libertés fondamentales le l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
vous avez parlé de complotisme tout à
l'heure n'empêche pas la liberté
d'opinion
n'empêche pas la liberté d'expression
n'empêche pas il empêche simplement de
se déplacer comme on l'entend mais
l'état d'urgence sanitaire par hypothèse
il est un équilibre entre le respect des
libertés et le respect de la santé
publique
mais jean louis debré vous voyez bien
que un équilibre d'aider des projets ou
des hypothèses de rendre obligatoire
l'isolément des cas pose problème
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème oui mais mais mais
je je pour moi c'est pas ça pose pas de
problème c'est à dire que d'abord c'est
à l'état et au gouvernement de prendre
ses responsabilités pour l'état pour la
vaccination obligatoire jeu
c'est une décision je pense que ce qui
est en cause c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres et vous savez que la
liberté votre liberté se termine où
commence la liberté des autres
et donc si il apparaît évident que la
contamination peut s'arrêter par la
vaccination
alors il ya un moment où il faudra se
poser la question du caractère
obligatoire
mais j'ajoute que je vaccine contre la
grippe et la grippe se transmet mais on
n'a pas rendu la vaccination contre la
grippe obligatoire on vaccine alors il
ya une vaccination qui je crois
obligatoire c'est la rougeole pour les
enfants et on à éradiquer la rougeole
alors il ya un moment où gouvernés sont
des choix c'est prendre ses
responsabilités et entre la liberté
individuelle et la liberté collective il
faut choisir
alors ça nous amène directement à la à
la situation politique
on va reprendre sa dent deux ou trois
minutes le temps de faire une petite
pause on se retrouve
[Musique]
on se retrouve sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec jean louis debré
l'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel
à l'occasion notamment de la sortie de
son de son livre la rumeur aux éditions
robert laffont
alors je dois préciser contrairement
peut-être ce que vous avez pensé quand
on a parlé de votre livre c'est pas un
essai politique que vous avez fait ça
polar qui se situe dans les milieux
politiques
c'est ça votre votre votre trip sas et
c'est le thriller
d'ailleurs on fera un film où derrière
ça se prépare ça se prépare
ouais vous souvenez de ce film
formidable de jean gabin le président
oui absolument
il était déjà sujet à un certain nombre
de rumeurs 1
cette tirade est ordinaire mais la
politique c'est souvent le fondement de
la politique c'est la rumeur ont réagi à
des rumeurs est plus qu à des réalités
oui alors jean louis debré la situation
politique elle n'est pas très clair
actuellement enfin la la la gouvernance
est compliqué la pandémie suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude après les gilets
jaunes le terrorisme islamique suscite
également de langoat ça fait quand même
beaucoup tout ça alors c'est quoi votre
lecture c'est c'est un exécutif qui
manque d'autorité je pense que je crois
me souvenir que vous l'avez dit ya pas
très longtemps
vous avez peut-être aussi des
institutions qui sont un peu fatigués
une mondialisation est un monde digital
qui change tout c'est quoi votre analyse
c'est plus compliqué que ça d'abord on a
envie dans un monde qui est un monde
hyper médiatisé et donc on ne peut pas
se référer aux anciennes pratiques
ça comme conséquence que la politique
est devenue un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique
je prends un exemple lorsque je suis
arrivée au conseil constitutionnel j'ai
eu à examiner une des premières lois
c'était la loi sur de lutte contre
l'immigration illégale et je me suis
rendu compte que c'était la troisième en
quatre ans et que les autres les
précédentes lois n'avait pas été
appliquée il n'y avait pas eu de décrets
d'application pourquoi pas ce qu'il faut
faire quand il faut faire il faut
essayer de donner l'impression qu'on
bouge de donner l'impression qu'on fait
quelque chose et on fait une loi de
lutte contre l'immigration peu importe
qu'on applique pas mais on a donné
l'image de et donc on vit aujourd'hui le
politique vit dans ce monde de la
communication où il faut faire croire où
il faut faire semblant
ça c'est la première chose deuxièmement
on vit dans un monde où on a été envahie
par un libéralisme une mondialisation
que qui finalement est dramatique et qui
a fait perdre à tous nos concitoyens des
réflexes les réflexes de de la nation
l'arrêt réflexe de l'europe
là on accepte qu'une entreprise se
délocalise en chine parce que c'est
moins cher et on appauvrit nos pays au
profit d'autres cette mondialisation
débridée sol et les produits fabriqués
dans ces pays revienne en france moins
cher parce que ces pays ne sont pas
soumis aux législations qui sont les
nôtres et notamment les charges sur le
travail
donc on a on a par cette mondialisation
introduit le monde de l'anarchie le
monde de l'absence de solidarité
troisièmement la mondialisation a abouti
à la disparition des idéologies on ne
croit plus
plus personne pardon de vous le dire le
roi ou communisme il n'y a pas eu un
pays marxiste qui a respecté la liberté
il ya personne ne croit au libéralisme
et donc on a perdu les grandes
références on ne sait plus où on est et
enfin ça c'est une une surprise le monde
politique français ne fabrique plus
aujourd'hui de grands personnages on a
eu de gaulle on a eu mitterrand elle a
eu chirac on a eu jusqu'à c'était des
personnages qui s'imposent et on ne
pouvait pas on pouvait ne pas les
apprécier on doit on pouvait ne pas les
aimer
on ne pouvait pas ne pas vous pouvez ne
pas les suivre mais il incarnait quelque
chose aujourd'hui à droite et à gauche
il n'y a rien il ya des notables de
province qui sont là et on a perdu le
sens du chef le change
enfin on vit dans une société où on a
perdu le sens de l'effort et du travail
et donc tout ça aboutit à une situation
qui est difficile
oui alors bon j'écoute a passionné par
contre votre exposé mon rôle n'est pas
débattre avec vous mais ya certains
points quand même qu'ils mériteraient
des précisions de votre part alors je
voudrais être plus précis lorsque vous
parlez de
de l'excès de loi parce que c'est un peu
ça que vous avez dit tout à l'heure au
conseil constitutionnel vous êtes aperçu
que vous aviez des lois qui avait déjà
été fait
vous voulez dire là que les lois ne sont
pas appliquées en france pour contenu
obligatoirement love ville ait besoin
d'en faire d'autres
et je voudrais prendre l'exemple
actuellement de la loi sur la sécurité
globale
vous avez quand même un avis là dessus
oui j'ai dit oui à cette loi cette loi
est l'exemple type de la loi instrument
que la communication politique
de quoi s'agit-il dans l'article 24 de
s'opposer à la diffusion d'image
malveillantes haineuse vis-à-vis des
policiers ceci justifie alors deux
choses premièrement premièrement
pourquoi une loi nouvelle
vous avez dans notre arsenal juridique
toutes les dispositions qui permettent
de lutter contre la diffusion de fausses
nouvelles
deuxièmement si on veut vraiment lutter
contre ça il faut responsabiliser et
pouvoir condamner les hébergeurs des
réseaux sociaux
or là on ne fait rien comment vous et en
plus cette loi est totalement inutile
comment voulez vous empêcher un
journaliste de filmer pendant une
manifestation vous avez des milliers de
personnes qui ont ça et qui filme c'est
ridicule
donc on a fait une loi à la demande d'un
certain nombre de syndicats
inutile inapplicable
mais pour faire plaisir appliquons
appliquant le droit je prends un autre
exemple je prends un exemple on annonce
une grande roisin grande loi sur la
laïcité parfait mais la constitution
article premier dit la france est une
république une indivisible laïque et
bien c'est toute la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état est là et on sanctionne
ceux qui portent atteinte au principe de
laïcité
quand on veut faire une loi sur le
séparatisme donc donc ciblé si on fait
ces lois alors que nous avons
arsenal législatif suffisant ça veut
dire qu'on les applique pas mais qu on
fait une loi pour l'opinion publique ont
fait nous le disait le grand philosophe
on fait une loi pour une opinion
publique pour calmer l'opinion publique
parce que les lois précédentes n'ont pas
été appliquées c'est à dire parce que
c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas parce
qu'on est
mais parce qu'on mais parce qu'on les
applique pas mais non mais parce que la
foudre mais mais mais je suis désolé
elles sont appliquées cancan
quant aux prenez la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état sur le principe de
laïcité
la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel nous avons annulé des
textes qui portait atteinte à la laïcité
le conseil d'état a annulé un certain
nombre décision c'est ça l'état de droit
mais jean louis debré c'est bien parce
que c'est bien parce que l'appareil
juridique le pouvoir exécuter pouvoir
judiciaire ne fait pas son travail
mais le pouvoir je le pouvoir judiciaire
il tranche des cas précis et la roue
prenez la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état sur la laïcité
je crois que le principe de laïcité a
été violée et bien la décision du
conseil d'état y tomber et a cassé la
décision quand un jour dans une
jurisprudence on refusait un religieux
de passer un concours
eh bien on a on a cassé cette décision
parce qu'on n'a pas à prendre en compte
la religion des uns et des autres bon
tout est là mais on n'a pas mais mais il
faudrait pour faire une piqûre de rappel
alors on y va on va faire une loi sur la
laïcité mais pour dire quoi en plus je
prends la loi sur le séparatisme là la
france est une république une et
indivisible
le poids des mots vous dire quelque
chose mais comme il faut faire croire
comme il veut donner l'impression d'en
faire une loi nouvelle
et comme disait montesquieu trop de lois
tuent la loi et les lois inutiles tu les
beaunois alors ça c'est pour la société
du spectacle
sur le chapitre mondialisation ou alors
là vous ne manquez pas de
de nervosité un pur pour combattre cette
ce courant de vivacité de vivacité
vous vous semblez omettre complètement
le fait que le consommateur
le citoyen a créé la mondialisation il a
il a revendiqué cette libre circulation
de biens de produits de services de
monde
le multilatéralisme ça existe et vous
avez travaillé avec un président de la
république qui le défendent eh oui à
condition que les règles du jeu soient
les mêmes
absolument on passe absolument quand on
passe
et voilà et on voit bien aujourd'hui sur
les accords qu'on passe avec cassandre
deux pays sur l'importation de viande
qu'ils respectent pas les décisions
qu'ils ont prises
on voit bien que dans d'autres pays on
respecte pas les droits de l'homme est
alors la mondialisation explique si nous
avons tous les mêmes règles et les mêmes
devoirs
or ce n'est pas le cas alors non c'est
pas le cas est l'un des pays qui
respectent le moins
toutes ces règles c'est quand même un de
nos fournisseurs principaux c'est à dire
la chine qui à un moment de l'om s'était
engagé un certain nombre de règles et de
contrôles et ne les a pas suivis
elle ne respecte pas ça nous emmènerait
dans un autre débat
juni nous reste très peu de temps
malheureusement il ya une chose que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure qui a accroché
mon oreille à savoir que la classe
politique ne produisait plus d'hommes
politiques responsables qui est-ce qui a
qui a aujourd'hui dans le paysage qui
aurait le logiciel pour être
éventuellement un président de la
république
oh je savais à mon grand âge je n'ai pas
la mémoire des non non non mais comment
se fait-il justement que non je vous
appelle à vous donner au delà vous
exagérez là au delà des noms au délà de
noms je constate que notre histoire de
france
notre histoire politique que je connais
bien a toujours
sorti des personnages qui sortait de
l'ordinaire
or aujourd'hui est bien mais
probablement une des conséquences de la
médiatisation
il n'y a plus de grand leader qui
s'imposent de grands héros de la
politique mais comme il y avait jadis
mais jean louis debré c'est peut-être
parce que les gens de grande qualité
préfèrent aller dans le business dans
les milieux d'affaires parce que le
pouvoir
il est peut-être dans le dans le
business et dans les milieux d'affaires
mais mais mais je partage votre idée moi
j'ai été élevé une époque où le but
c'était à un moment ça reste de sa vie
s'engager en politique aujourd'hui parce
que c'est ainsi eh bien allez les
garçons et les filles que je collais qui
sont ma génération suivante préféré
aller dans le business gagner de
l'argent plutôt que de subir la
politique avec l'inconnue sur ce qu'on
va dire sur vous sur cette calomnie et
ces gens ne devraient pas seulement pour
gagner de l'argent
on peut considérer avoir de l' influence
sur la soliste sur la société sur la
sueur sur sur la collectivité dans le
business le digital a eu beaucoup
d'influencé et c'est pas un résultat
produit
mais me jean louis debré sûr c'est que
je voulais le gramme par doré jean louis
debré je sais que il nous reste des
êtres que secondes vous préparer là vous
vous écrivez puisque vous écrivez
pendant les confinements donc vous
terminez un deuxième revenu l'ailé je
mets en scène quoi a coûté vous verrez
vous mourrez inviterez quand il paraîtra
écouter en attendant on peut se procurer
le bouquin parce que les librairies sont
ouvertes a maintenant on n'est plus
obligé de ne passer que par amazon a on
peut aussi aller dans les librairies la
rumeur c'est chez robert laffont
merci en tous les cas de vos
explications merci de votre de votre
gentillesse
on retrouve cette émission sur l'antenne
de 2 et arte france bien sûr en replay
on la retrouve sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis sur le site internet de rtl
france point tv merci beaucoup merci
jean louis debré
bientôt merci à vous
je
[Musique]